all right and we are loved welcome to
the I Lords podcasts and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 111 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day and
today the round will rejoice we have the
debut of the e3 2019 prediction series
and Nintendo is first up to bet I'm
extremely proud to have all this
Nintendo royalty here at the round table
so we gonna get right into it I want to
introduce a Lord who is the only one of
the best followers on Twitter but it's
always a fantastic addition to any
podcast panel his passion for the
Nintendo brand is everything everything
he does well at the same time providing
the hottest takes an expert gaming
analysis introducing the global market
researcher by day and master of JRPGs by
night the Lord formerly with three
underscores to his name one of the very
few Lords to not ranks Elder breadth of
the world in his top 5 sell the games of
all time generally laugh of Nintendo New
York in making his debut into the realm
of the Lords mommy Lord stealth 40k how
you doing sir I'm doing great but you
can play a bit I've been playing Final
Fantasy 10 on my switch quite a lot I
have to say I've put about 80 hours in
maybe five days so I've been playing it
a lot wow I think I think he got you
beat so happy to have you man love you
takes minute are you ready to have some
fun sir I'm ready
that's what I want to hear man good good
that and of course we have the young
lord of video production and potentially
one of the most talented and sarcastic
Nintendo content created throughout the
realm introducing the host of the
potentially perfect YouTube channel and
creator of the critically
claimed hero a lot series one of ILP
stream teams favorites and the Lord who
still rolls his eyes every time SNES
games are not announced for switch or a
live state or making his return to the
realm of the Lord's mom made Lord de la
Pole aka potentially perfect how you
doing sir I'm doing them back out here
did you download an eagle's hot on the
Tendo classics yes I know you mean the
urge was so there that you just forgot
just right into the bushes we go have
some fun out here you already know every
time no doubt and of course we have our
Lord who was no stranger to the realm of
legality not only is this Lord the
founder one of the biggest corporate law
firms he still finds the time to grace
us with the hottest aches in pop culture
MCU film rankings and the kind of course
multi-platform gaming
introducing the attorney and host of the
hog law business law firm and YouTube
channel creative the outstanding virtual
legality series and the Lord who still
has the Nintendo Lambo product line
boldly ranked number seven it is top 10
games of 2018 from Michigan and making
his return into the realm of the Lord's
mom me Lord Richard hole guy you doing
sir I'm doing great you know I think
this is my third or fourth time on with
you guys and I every single time I
wonder if I can't have you introduce me
introductions like that you want
something when he comes in the courtroom
that's how you want Cognito Oh
Reuben he gets like an introduction like
that no opposing counsel wouldn't know
what's even going on it would be like
wrestling at your boxing match would be
great
always a pleasure to have in the realm
how's that lab Oh doing man oh oh we
just got lab OVR uh we've been enjoying
taking pictures of underwater sea life
all around our living room it's a good
time you know nightmare to me like I
said I've got two young daughters we put
them together they have some nice stuff
it's like salute the future of the realm
whoa I was actually doing fantastic so
it's good to see you and of course last
but certainly not least we have a lot
who I'm truly honored to call a friend
to the roundtable this Lord's work ethic
professionalism and passion for gaming
is evident in everything he does and
with his team of two six vests more and
paradise still remains one of the most
premier content creators in the game
introducing the host and co-founder of
the Eric's getting YouTube channel the
Lord of end game lifestyle in the Zillah
franchise and serge beard oil game on
fleek
live from UK of making his return into
the realm of the lords my main Lord
Eric's gaming how you doing sir I am
good I'm good - it's good to be back I
missed you guys and you know III I
second now I like this leading trade
services I'll pay good money for this
liquid every cell phone just like a TV
show yo yo
sign me up brother glad you guys
appreciate always have fun introducing
the Lords of Rome have you've been doing
what's been going on with the channel
man good man yeah just busy I mean you
know
we're getting close to e3 right so it's
that it's that kind of crazy time trying
to juggle like different games and
whatnot teams expanding which is uh
which is always awesome but yeah just
trying to just try to do as much as
possible trying to cover as much as
possible and obviously you know
relevance today try to sneak in as much
Nintendo as I can on the channel and
make sure people realize that a Nintendo
is king you got the whole flight to LA
to play there so it's exactly the King
and I in our show like twice no I wasn't
told we're going into Game of Thrones
today a lot of Game of Thrones to take
salute pleasure to have you back bad no
we got you for a limited time so we got
maximize experience get through the rest
of these intros for the Lord so you know
we have the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original modes the realm here at
the round table
my co-host with the cold lost my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the how of the young wolf
mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir doing
pretty good trying to emotionally
prepare myself for tonight for Game of
Thrones I don't think let's just be I'm
88% sure I'm gonna rant tonight after
Game of Thrones so we'll see my jaw
chorus playing sir I've been playing
Final Fantasy 7 and playing while I was
in stealth I don't know I don't believe
you man stuff sound like you going hard
on you with that dad you still baby in
those hours look it's a you beat all the
dark ions and pendulums like you can't
really come to me like that
GOP G King we're talking to right now I
should have noted that that was over
Saturday and Sunday only
it's a shame that you're on the switch
of no achievement so I can't check you
guys so that's all it's badass
yeah and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the selfish single-player
experience and also the sastra darkness
mr. Othman profile Illuminati and Lord
patreon of the iron bank mommy Lord
sovereign how you doing sir I'm good
ma'am chillin man just get this Nintendo
Talk what have you been playing Nathan I
downloaded the the Castlevania
Anniversary Collection for the switch
and I played a little bit cool little
collection on one out little it's a
plenty plenty of games and everything so
it's cool gameplay in the music
the hydrocele you see what we deal with
right now
yeah you got a fraud I need in the hater
light all right now and of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
excess gamer ooh the lord of combat
sports king of the statues who demands
nothing less than the premium experience
and is the leader of the fraud alert
movement fool beloved Lord King are you
doing sir I'm doing fantastic shout out
to the WBC heavyweight champion of the
world it's a body in the ring with that
first right hand oh when he hit him and
his body sprawled out I thought he did
catch that body in the ring but they was
leaving I know his soul was leaving he
said please wait fantastic um this week
I've been playing nothing but destiny
finishing up trying to be 700 yeah yes
Erick's yes Erick's I am NOT 700 so yes
the fraud light is on me hey I'm still
500 okay oh wow I've taken a couple back
seasons aback see today I really thought
I was in for that I was playing real
hard I knew you was coming this week I
was like I gotta get to 700 I can't man
and tell him I'm not 700 I'm trying to
get this stuff done so I can get on
Division two and get these raids
starting on Monday night
what PlayStation 4 is there's only one
clear no one else yet it's crazy that's
all the destiny people a play in there I
heard is absolutely crazy
um I didn't know this season of The
Drifter mm-hmm I mean a lot of guys talk
about they wanted content in this game I
didn't even know they had a own like
secret of the nine thing right you have
to get a little um there's a little
pamphlet um from um zur and instead of
just going to pick up exotics and stuff
like that he has a mission quest for you
yes now when you do these quests it's a
dream sequence that you see in a past
history of The Drifter and the level of
content that they put in and the thought
going forward and this is Bungie without
Activision oh boy this is fantastic I'm
not gonna front they actually made me
not pick up the vision to this week wow
what a range rate no no I'm not know how
much no I got a chance to do the
recommend and I got a chance to get to
level 3 tier 3 yeah I love the fact that
they said okay we didn't have a hard
moment now here's this hope is well
thought out yeah the brain to build the
bridge did you got to work together yeah
I saw all that but it's for reason it's
for a reason because this new content
there's a new Bungie in the ways that
these exotics got to work because the
whole way was set up with Activision is
BS O'Dell so you already know we have
the Lord of the cooperative's experience
and game earning himself the shinobi
Lord Cognito
spread narrowness in the realm of the
ILP not telling what you want to hear
but what you need to hear for me it's
just been all MK Levin still on a switch
Psalm I'm still playing at ninja Gator
but I had to kind of throw it into
pushes off the arm the arcade version of
ninja gaiden that came out on the um and
so after a while you realize yeah you
know it was a coach I we were young
right yeah I was pretty large sprites
you know I mean but it gave my mechanics
not as much started getting back on our
division to trying to Ray prep all that
good stuff but that has been it for me
so we gonna get into the show we are
limited
Time Lord Eric's we don't get him
rolling but uh before we start all the
Nintendo love got some breaking news so
most of the laws you know Twitter has
been very aware of what's been going on
has been broken
people are saying cars and crawling so
much that's a dog sleeping together you
know dog who's the cat oh my god Matt
gave ago I did what allowed to rule them
all so the agreement has been made is
the console is not an agreement is a
knee bend
every Sony dude the shea butter they
knees and I mean nice and chopped off
and put in the basket right next to you
I have shipped a basket to your house I
want you to take your knees moment just
is a sign seal off envelope that you're
gonna put you told you has been some
formal agreement between the hands Sony
and a Marcus off and now we want to talk
about that real quickly arm also we want
to also pertaining to Nintendo has the
Tendo been left at the altar here so um
I want to start off with Lord Eric's and
then also Lord Hawk and then stealth in
that sequence or Eric's when the news
broke what was your initial thought of
this partnership I mean initially it's
like it's it's like a sore about time
kind of thing right because we've known
up until this point invariably I know
this is a slightly different thing but
hopefully this is kind of like the
bridge to what we ultimately want for
gaming in general because up until this
point if ever you speak to like a
developer and they're like oh you know
if you've got crossed across platform
they are very like no because Sony
you're kind of hopefully a dragon there
Joe Murphy right so obviously if this is
the start of the partnership maybe this
will kind of lead to where we need to be
because we've seen you know see some
stuff earlier in the year well it
intended Microsoft are already kind of
you know it talks and kind of getting
friendly anyway a Microsoft I feel like
it's just in their background from you
know more so from a software point of
view they just want to they just want
this off everywhere
right they're pushing for that
accessibility all platforms so to them
it's just although yes they asked they
still have you know Xbox they are still
ultimately see Sony's a competition but
at the same time if you have access to
their services anywhere like it finally
like they just they just need to start
talking because I guess this with it
this point where like yeah I mean
obviously everyone's still but where
their favorite places but people just
wanna play games right like I'm not like
people always say you know ok I might I
might be like the message Nintendo fan
but the other day I just play games I
like right I don't really I don't have a
particular platform bias just might and
that's why they're spinning she needs to
go right because you know as
everything's going online more so it
makes more sense yeah no I hear you man
I definitely a reference to possibly
open up the future with a cross
progression and cross play it oh Lord
Hogan he had a tremendous virtual
legality recently in in just a legal
aspect of the agreement what kind of
things stood out to you let's get some
on legality in here low at home sure
yeah as you said I did a virtual
legality episode on this the day it came
out because it was such big news and
because I have experience doing joint
development agreements and memorandums
of understanding and I think they put
the actual term memorandums of
understanding in the press release so
that you know it's not a full License
Agreement it's not a full joint
development agreement I mean at this
point in time but unlike some other
voices on this podcast I don't really
see it as a full Daenerys requesting and
just so I clarify you're saying that
Sony is not bending the knee well here's
what I see in the press room you can
look at the press release yourself I do
cover this for a little I think 40
minutes in a virtual legality but you
can actually read the sentences in order
and see what the quid-pro-quo
likely is in the memorandum of
understanding so it looks like Microsoft
really wants access to some Sony
semiconductor secret sauce and if you're
familiar with Microsoft and Sony in
general the the thought process is Sony
does hardware Microsoft as software and
that's no surprise as to what the
memoranda of understanding actually
describes it says Microsoft's gonna have
all this software it as your that
they're gonna allow Sony access to and
Sony has some hardware secret sauce with
semiconductors that they're gonna allow
Microsoft to access to and hopefully
improve all of their services and
products so I really do think it can be
a joint
relationship and one where both sides
benefit okay these things don't always
result in actual output so if there's
still a long way to go to see what
happens but it's certainly a great first
step and I think it looks to me like
every consumer every video gamer will
benefit if there are improvements to
either side services and products so we
could think it more a Battle of
Winterfell with a a United yeah that's
where we go let's get some game with
don't references you know take that
we're gonna Lao that tujhe chorus ready
here we go with my we'll continue please
like follow subscribe and send those
needs them this way please thing enough
I know yes interesting takes on this
looks way as far as uh hyperbole in
people you know getting maybe a little
too excited so lost I want to get your
take on this Agreement this news this
week yeah so it's not really something
that's so surprising or shouldn't be
surprising to anybody
Microsoft has pretty much made it clear
that they want to move primarily from a
hardware company in the gaming space to
a services company so you know they've
been open to working with Nintendo and
you know they've talked about
potentially working with Sony if you
know the opportunity was right and this
seems like a good opportunity because
Sony's made it clear that they want to
use Microsoft's platform for cloud
gaming for streaming um and you know
Microsoft will get a lot of money from
that you know down the line as far as
the hyperbole yeah I mean the very first
thing I saw was you know having books on
games will be on and you know that's not
really what this is about at all
I mean Sony still the company that won't
allow cross play because they feel like
their ecosystem is superior so you know
people have
to slow down on that aspect great yeah
let me double it because we all apples
back other case in love so I want to ask
this question that the lava can jump in
as well
which is all right now with disagreement
right I'm like Nintendo right remember
initially we heard rumors of Nintendo
I'm like a soft kind of being the ones
to marry up first and partner up and
then this kind of like threw everything
for left there are now sony's in the
building so like is Nintendo left at the
altar yeah that sounds like what happens
man what do you big I don't think so um
switch is very very appealing to
Microsoft for one simple reason
and that's switch is dominating Japan
which Microsoft has never been able to
get into so by putting so their
relationship is more software based
where Microsoft really wants to get as
many games as they can on to switch not
because they see it as some graphical
powerhouse competitors because it opens
up like a 10 million gamer market to
them that they never had before
absolutely and you know even just
cuphead I forget where I read it but
like cuphead did the best on switch in
Japan even not even versus PC Wow so you
know just getting it on there was very
important and you know this just because
Microsoft's working with Sony on this
doesn't mean down the line they can't
work with Nintendo that it's not like
there's an exclusivity agreement so ROM
but Nintendo's said that you know
they're interested in you know in
streaming services they just don't
believe it's mainstream yet or you know
they aren't pooh-poohing it but they
aren't necessarily wanting to dive into
it now right what would that you
somebody said right yeah no I was just
gonna jump in and it's what we agree
with the lack of exclusivity there you
don't see that referenced in the
memorandum of understanding press
release at all and it would be a
surprise if it were there honestly
Microsoft wants to put xbox live wants
to have everybody on the planet using
Azure they can sell it to them that's a
service that's a business that they're
selling they're not competing with Sony
or Nintendo in respective Azure they're
competing with Amazon and Google so they
want every customer on their servers
their cloud services if they can and
that's what this is a
outso Nintendo wasn't left at the altar
isn't out in the cold this is just Tony
coming in and joining them around the
heart that's right drink to from the
chalice cats and dogs sleeping together
well what did you think meds news broke
where were you when it when it I'm not
really surprised when I saw it I was
like they've gotta do something to stave
off stadia and it was all like it's it
was coming eventually as far as intended
goes I don't know the I've always held
it they have like this really weird
attachment to their IP when it comes to
streaming I never I feel like that's why
we're only getting NES game to be honest
saying oh that's landed I mean you even
in retail you don't see price drops and
things like that so I feel like that
feeds into how they feel about streaming
as a whole but once Nintendo does
eventually start streaming I feel like
it's gonna have one of the most powerful
impacts on shrink games because of their
IPs and what they have and I think I
don't ever want to hear you put Nintendo
and powerful in you know but it's really
good honestly I'm really happy to see I
don't like all the family ISM stuff I
think this the more we come together on
this the sooner the console were
nonsensical and and we can just get back
to enjoying games I feel you develop
long as everybody bends to needed one
true king we gotta be one ring to rule
them all let's go
telling you John Snow John field ominous
snow had to get out no I saw them I
battled them just so we're clear Kings
now referencing Sauron and Daenerys
Targaryen I need your feedback sir we
got to talk about it man what do you
think when this news broke man I mean I
agree with the LA boy like it really
didn't surprise me too much I mean we've
seen this sort of stuff in the past
obviously you know everybody pays
Microsoft to use havoc so I mean that's
that's nothing new
obviously when it comes to blu-ray and
stuff like that that's you know you pay
Sony in conjunction with somebody else
for that so you're gonna be using that
tech I thought was interesting about it
was that it was very forward facing they
made sure to take a nice picture and
then right so I think what they're
realizing is yeah yeah the optics are a
little bit different but I just think a
it was a smart move on Sony's part
especially because of they just don't
have the infrastructure to compete
directly with Microsoft and do their own
thing and you know if you're gonna go
with a devil you go with the devil that
you know right you don't know me not
gonna get in bed with Google I don't
know if Google would even entertain
something like that so you you know I
guess the the the big three in gaming
per se are gonna stick together there so
you know say way that into the Nintendo
thing yeah I I think that I think there
is no issue with Nintendo and I honestly
think that it's gonna be part of my
predictions I think that we're gonna
have some streaming talk from Nintendo
you know in India not if not in their
direct and in the treehouse presentation
something no Lord added your twitter has
been on fire recently with all this news
so where you at with the the coming
together of margasoft and Sony in this
Groening everyone's scared of Google I
don't think that's endo is out of it I
think if anything this is Sony if
Microsoft's mistress right now mm-hmm
and it
is the old lady back at the house
there's more concubines we're gonna see
I don't know as of right now I can't see
Nintendo announcing anything streaming
wise right but it wouldn't surprise me
that this is this is direction clearly
the entire industry is going that's the
reason Sony partnered with them because
everyone knows it's going this direction
boss Wu says switches decide because
I've done movie Lord I know I saw some
feet from you people were DMing me
saying I cannot wait for King to speak
on this subject so King the floor is
yours is this the moment everybody gotta
play for the same team
I want the lipo to go back and get my on
my voice cues for when I told everybody
that everybody must bow down Dominus and
I said it and I told you I remember the
visualization when Phil was in the
middle yeah he xed out left and he
exhale right now I'm gonna tell you this
I guarantee you Reggie's the realest guy
here okay I gotta get ready respect I
know Reggie saw stuff was like was such
a man of principle with the ten you know
evil cloud infrastructure know what do
you know is this what we say you know
listen I know you guys like okay he's
wacky he's not you know listen I told
you that they was gonna play together
they had to disturb Steve all about
other people that was coming and
everybody was like that had never
happened until you're sort of tweeting
it was like oh god no and when you
dreaded this day run from
hide from it oh I am inevitable it will
happen and now turns out well we don't
know because there's so many timelines
are then opened up now right now y'all
see what's going on right now
does this sad part is as gamers we
shouldn't be divided these guys are a
divided a in the background working
together so the truce has been gone the
knees has been bent there is no more oh
we are the rulers we must band together
I love my switch y'all hear me snap on
it and all that stuff you know what
original content okay that's it right
there that's all I want is original
content I will purchase Oh
my Sony I love my Sony for the original
content alright so but they
infrastructure sup but now if I can get
like Xbox Live on Sony boy like that
opens up like an xbox live on my switch
and I can get cross progression if I can
get stuff that PC has been doing for
years on my console then that change is
how we gonna gain with each other could
you imagine 5 to 6 million people on
different consoles playing the division
or playing oh yes I guess that's at that
unless let's get to where gaming is pure
this is what we're going for
so if if some people had to be xed out
and other bosses had to be put in traced
because it was more palatable to what
was going forward Reggie's commander
gotta stop the guard and you know what
he went out on his shield and he said
I'm not doing that but two weeks later
we were in bed with Microsoft and in
sorry to say Microsoft's like everyone I
say this and then did they feel still
live and I'm looking around and those
are the two people that was in the
picture on it
Oh Lord salute Sujatha BC's
with king is tyrion lanister my last one
of the I mean it that the panel you guys
knocked it out the part I mean obviously
you know it basically Sony offering
these cutting-edge digital imaging
sensors and Microsoft with that cloud
infrastructure so we see how that goes
it is to me Game of Thrones on the
enterprise level though hope it was like
which is coming man you know they had to
unite against what man feel no - the
night king you don't say he's coming
goodness stadia they may be scared of
that Harrison man but all jokes aside
okay I think that's right I think that
they see the they see the winter coming
in terms of streaming and the big tech
giants because the tech giants could
enter any industry they want and really
make waves and if they're gonna enter
into gaming then you best figure out
where you're gonna we're gonna hang
don't feel bad if it's anything like
this show it's not that much of a threat
Oh stealth made a great point too you
can't you can't underestimate the the
Sony's desire to get back on top in
Japan and in some way shape or form
because Nintendo is eating their lunch
right now
pretty much the only Achilles heel Sony
really had was kind of like the um as
far as their infrastructure and like
look you know let's be clear like Sony
could have picked AWS they could have
Clinton cloud I mean Google cloud I mean
instead of ashes so they recognized as
you're making the best sense on top and
you know as a global crowd and being
that they even competitors in the
gainsaying gaming space so it's like you
know that they didn't have to do that
moves basically what I'm trying to say
you know there's gonna be interesting
but all let's talk about got a war gonna
be on you know guess little PlayStation
you know to me this is relationship at
the very top enterprise level you know
one would assume though like Eric's is
saying that these talks this transitions
into something like cross play across
progression on the console side and I'm
saying it's being that well they're all
living under the same as your roof so to
speak and last mile just very curious to
see how markets off is going to
implement these digital image search
sensors for an AI from Sony because
clearly they coveted that and I'm saying
all this is very intriguing so at the
end a man cloud infrastructure man is I
guess power the cloud does mean
something different
taking us one step closer to Skynet is
almost there alright that's all I got on
it we're going to move on so let's get
into the reason we are here state of
Nintendo let's do a little brief recap
of 2019 you know switch has been really
moving out here close to thirty five
million sold
even though ps4 had the three-year head
start in Japan they're now ahead of them
in Japan you know I'm saying with our
besides our lifetime sales you know Lord
Reggie has retired the Bowser era has
begun it's a lot of uh software now so
it's gonna bring this to the realm
roundtable like how are we feeling about
Nintendo coming into e3 so let's start
with stealth and then let's get Eric's
right after so so how we feeling right
now um well I think Nintendo should feel
very confident going into this e3 mom
I've never
Ramin I haven't remembered in III where
I felt that Nintendo didn't have to
announce a single game and they could
just talk about what's already announced
and feel great about it that doesn't
kind of where we're at
um we're at a point where pretty much
from June to December they should have
at least two games they're publishing
every month um which is crazy um so yeah
they should feel very good I know I felt
very good not necessarily because
Nintendo's put out a lot you know from
January to now but you know third
parties have sort of filled the gap for
me yeah um but yet in terms of first
party pretty much from here on out it's
gonna be crazy for Nintendo
strong outlook this or Lord Eric's how
we feel is state of Nintendo coming in
yeah I mean I'm super like for me
Nintendo the ones that I always admires
on e3 I mean obviously I'm a massive fan
anyway but also partly because when you
actually physically attend they're like
they're the past three years they've had
like a massive like though their booth
is just killer every year and they pick
their game they pick their theme and
they go like all out on that and this
year's an interesting one I'm cutting
I'm kind of sort of thinking about what
they're the main theme and my focus
would be and I feel like you have like a
split booth this year because obviously
Pokemon which to be massive they
obviously still got I mean firearms
coming just after e3 so I feel like it
might not be like a huge focus for them
per se um you've got there's a remake
and then people are still wondering
whether we're gonna get Animal Crossing
this year not sure I'm still not too
sure that all but yeah I mean like the
fact that yeah obviously on like a on a
first-party side the the first model
years been a little bit slow but this
just know is this there's a ton of great
stuff and honestly I've been getting
through so many great indie titles this
year as well um so it's one of those
things where for Nintendo I just I get I
get kind of excited about everything
later they announce not just first party
because it just seems to be so like it's
been a great platform for me to
experience like other games that I might
not normally have plates a lot of people
like this year and last year I've been
indie titles of me my last year you know
like dead cells even though you know
I've been out before dead cells on us
which was great movies great this year
katana zero so I'm definitely which is
funny because in conferences when it
comes to like Microsoft or Sony went off
when they get they kind of indie section
I like it can tends to be where I drift
off a little bit but I guess because the
portability nature I'll switch I'm
always like yeah this is where it is
where I'm at for that so yeah I'm fully
I'm excited to see like every aspect of
what they have I think it's me strong I
think it's gonna be like they it's also
III as a whole is quite different cuz
they revealed their the the show format
this year in right yeah obviously we
know Sony's not there there's not
Activision they're you know have a press
conference they obviously they're heavy
a play beforehand so like being on the
floor just looks by different in fact
like West Hall is basically just
Nintendo Mike yeah I thought South Hall
is you know the all the other like
publishers are more rpm West West Hall
is basically just intend oh and I think
it because I love that so yeah they're
just basically Nintendo also yeah oh
yeah that's right yes correct Korea yeah
Matt Lord Allah oh man how we feel in
statement end oh well we at now man so
there's gonna be a lot of fan bases
watching this one from the Nintendo side
there's a lot of franchises they should
get announcements or you know further
discussions mean some of the worst
Nintendo fan bases like Fire Emblem
Animal Crossing and Pokemon just those
three alone you got that platinum
nonsense okay easy
no-nobody type really I'm really excited
for this one I'm I'm so ready to get
more details on a lot of stuff I think I
have one of my biggest things is like
the animal crossing one yeah now how
they're gonna of all this franchise cuz
they always do something like when it
comes back to switch like since it's
gonna be on switch I think it's gonna be
something radical emitting to me
something really awesome and something
that I can actually find entertaining
because I usually amble crossing
I feel like something about being it
being on the switch is gonna be it's
gonna take you out to switch I gotta say
Dolapo I love when you say that word
radical yes of it Lord
Oh what do we feel it man has that
switch feeling for you coming in the III
well so I love my switch you know I
played a bow on it with my kids but we
do outside of that outside of that I
think you know they came in so strong
with 2017 that was such an unbelievable
year I think at least for me it's taken
me a little time to recover from that
and for a Nintendo to recover from that
in terms of their development pathways
but like some of the other people that
have already spoken
I think the portability of the switch
has made me love indie games things
below a certain threshold thing and I've
been playing a ton of them and every
time they're on the PC and the
PlayStation and the Xbox and the switch
I'm almost always getting them on my
switch because the switch can handle
those games and I can play them wherever
I want so I've been playing a game that
I'd never heard of which I understand
came out on the PC last year called Mass
Kurata songs and shadows absolutely
fantastic couldn't recommend it more 20
bucks it's an action RPG with a with a
fantasy world like Game of Thrones and
it's been it's been great it's been a
great find and I probably would never
picked it up except I'm always kind of
sifting through the switch and seeing
what I can what I can play at the office
what I can play when I'm otherwise
available outside of the home and so I
think the switch is always going to be
strong for what it is but I'm not as
invested in Animal Crossing and Pokemon
and Fire Emblem so we're still not back
up to Mario and Zelda releasing in the
same year for me okay but I think
they're going to continue to have a
strong year absolutely no doubt Lord
addict how we feeling coming in well why
do I got to have
it's for like the racing myself I'm
bracing myself I felt like it was like
what's that that moment were you scared
to pass the microphone
Wow you feel a confident feeling good
about it I mean to my knowledge Luigi's
Mansion is still coming out
you got that Pokemon Fire Emblem you
even regardless I don't care about
animal crossing people I know that still
got a huge following you just came off
of Super Smash Brothers are still
releasing information on that they're
going into the next Pokemon game with
this little uh the boat the Pikachu get
a movie that just came out yes so they
they properly built this up so I can't I
can't fault them on him Lord King where
are we at with the expectation of the
Tendo come back this is the one you
should be scared to pass the mic to get
it is get it down so knowing that last
year we felt that their little direct
bone thing was trash oh I liked it we it
was only good for smash you're living in
Kings world no no no actually if you had
to be three with us that's fine you two
got up and left me incognito as well I
mean I do agree that you know unless you
were a smash fan it probably wasn't the
greatest I am patient and actually the
two directs they had afterward were
better than you it was definitely better
right
yeah we watched and we waited and we
pleaded with who with everybody that was
around us to stick around because we
thought something spectacular was gonna
happen because we know at their presence
at e3 is fantastic I'm not gonna lie
like Eric says when you go there their
presence is second to none
alright you gets in a Nintendo section
and it is like shoulders shoulder elbow
and elbow you can walk through it you
can you know you're putting your cameras
away you're trying to get to your little
interviews you're trying to do as much
as you possibly can as early as Walmart
get out of my day
don't think I don't think that's that's
accurate but I think they got more
traffic going through there than a
Walmart on Black Friday but you give it
at least like low-key get around a
little bit on Black Friday you come to a
home it is definitely the main attractor
I think Nintendo has always captured
that youthful exuberance when they do
these shows yeah um so going into a
Nintendo this year like attic says I
really do believe that they're gonna
have the best year out of the three Tony
has already folded up the tent and moved
on Microsoft is gonna give you the best
III that they got they're gonna show you
exactly why everybody else been to me um
I expect Nintendo to make some form of
announcement I know Michaels will
probably said well let Sony go first we
already know yeah I just truly expect
man Tendo to have a spectacular end to
the year like they had to the beginning
so I don't really care for Animal
Crossing but I got three kids upstairs
they do so financially I'm invested in
Animal Crossing even though I don't want
to be and I might buy three switches
this year of Animal Crossing many come
no I'm not buying or they are they not
gonna get switched they're not buying a
bus which we don't want to have switch
you guys pick it up this Pokemon game
you're gonna frog like you
[Applause]
this is your Pokemon it's my Pokemon
bring weight after frauding though after
me that you fraud it upfront and then
you said right with us right you guys
said that those were made for you
there's no way I was getting once I
found out what that was there was no way
I was getting that and neither was that
you knew that I'm pissed off because
we're not getting witness no dissension
in the ranks there's too much agreement
agreement that you you know ice funny
huh there's a lot of revisionist history
going on you know you can go back to the
tapes right we have added we have added
thinking just bending the knee and now
I'm not getting any to stop it you came
in here and you agreed with everything I
expected some some irrational
unreasonable point
okay no no King
the Lord called me know I take back
everything I said anything this year man
asked bro that is the Attic but I know
we love apologize because they want me
to rant like a man man on some point
that I feel that there was definitely no
you want to see you anywhere anyway yeah
so yeah they I agree with stuff on this
like they really they don't have to
announce anything new and it still like
they just talking about stuff they've
talked about it really like if you
really think about it at the beginning
of the year was kind of slow right you
had music Mario you knew you had Yoshi's
crafting world which is very kitty like
very simplistic beautiful game but not
you're not gonna move the needle and
then you had on where's the Traverse
strikes again which was yeah whatever
mom everything else that either they're
publishing or the developing first party
coming down the pipeline is probably
coming out this year we probably get
dates for e3 it's kind of insane when
you think about it to at least to first
party or published games by them per
month throughout to the rest of the end
of the year that's kind of insane man I
mean Animal Crossing you have zelda
links awakening to remake you have that
other game freak RPG town that they said
supposedly supposed to be coming out
this year of course Ultimate Alliance
astral chain Pokemon sword and shield
and and Mario maker we get Mario maker
can that we get Mary Omega marrow maker
I when I first saw it I said okay I'm
actually picking that up day one America
coming us cuz I thought it was gonna be
you know you always you always wonder if
it's just gonna be one of those you know
right-click save as you know and and
over and the last ten minutes of that
was all new stuff they added to that
game kind of insane so and of course
Fire Emblem as well so to me hands down
they just have to talk about that stuff
and give release dates for most of that
and if most of that is coming this year
it did it's it's an it's gonna be
amazing show and it's me it's like King
said like the presence there booth is
always the greatest then you've got to
remember afterwards the the the
treehouse stuff is a little slow but at
the same time what they did to sort of
mitigate that's almost a little bit is
that they give you actual announcements
during that as well likely announced
amich returns they're like so you're
always gonna get little announcement
sprinkled in there then you have
Nintendo World Championships for smash
and for splatoon so they keep you
engaged in their booth the entire time
like it really is theirs we've been talk
about Microsoft and what they're gonna
do with it just any other Nintendo's
presence there it can't be understated
like it I think they're gonna have a
great show I really do I'm gonna finish
my point and then get into all
predictions because I want to get a
Ericsson before you leave so yeah
literally same thing I agree with
completely all the panel on this I think
that the UM you know more and more you
starting to see third-party
full-featured exclusives like The Mortal
Kombat things of that nature you know it
is the de facto home for Indies right
now I mean it's not even close he's
starting to see a lot of that stuff
really thrive you know all the Lords
have spoken multiple developers and you
know they generally the consensus seems
to be that they their title does well as
a port on the switch and um yeah a lot
they're gonna exceed what we're gonna
have revealed so a Mario maker - you
know I'm saying that's that's gonna be a
big one so we're gonna see what goes on
so I want to switch up no Eris is not
much long I'm gonna go to predictions
expectation my crops and let's get Eric
before he goes cuz this one I'm dying to
know from Lord a so all blood Alex man
what do you feel like what are your
predictions your all your expectations
or just any may be possible might drop
moments for you for three that direct
like what what do you need Erik's let
stuff go go for things so one of them is
it's one of those weird things right
like it feels fine so always hope for
like a port of things but there's some
games that go wrong with you that I just
I just want to play again man so like a
wind waker HD on switch would be real
nice will not buy that day one exactly
right there's so many games i don't
matter how many Zelda's come out I'll
buy them all I think we wake her back in
the game few days but I bought it on Wii
U but I still have a play that is still
sealed for my way you copy cuz it just
didn't we news didn't get to go didn't
get much time for me so that that I mean
like to be fair
Zola is my number one serious I'll take
any Zelda whether they do like Skyward
Sword HD or Twilight Princess but wait I
think I feel like wind wakers the one
that I really really want to see so that
I'll be there yeah go on in light of
like a recent release imagine if they
announced and is a far-fetched one right
through exclusiveness which Dogma
imagine in magically well that's another
one of those games that when it came out
it kind of I didn't really get the
traction he kind of it I don't think
that's for affairs I think that's
something that they would go for some
hopes though then the third one right I
mean this is probably not gonna happen
at all but you know well before they
announced Link's Awakening remaster I
was like the one thing that I've missed
for this for the longest time is four
swords right for swords old on switch so
and what they could do a nobody world
but like four swords in some other games
has he always been collected okay kind
of a net extradition so imagine if they
did say they announced during e3 to in
the treehouse like oh by the way there's
also a new component we didn't tell you
about in the mixed we can remake where
is like a second version where you can
play for source that would be crazy
now be really cool I'll see that and
then also on the smash front I'm looking
for next character and I'm hoping I'm
just like I'm I'm hoping for from
monster hunter character a key way they
did it like Momo vs. Capcom but just so
we see because I'm just like well if you
look at the roster right you look
everything they've got they've literally
only got Wrath loss as a monster but
they don't have any of like the other
stuff it's like a big gaping hole there
and they're either doing that because
they save it because obviously if a
character comes like well you see when
my joke about how did they have a ton of
like experiences stuff on persona and so
maybe they'll even that there because
they're thinking it could be so I mean I
mean can your capital understand it
doesn't make sense they would have so
much assets but not a character right
yeah yeah it's like you know you got you
got and they've got such a great
relationship now let this work in
relationship but I think myself you know
what alright my son is on switch side
mislead generational so it was more of a
support but it's got only now that would
be amazing no crazy yeah I don't even
care how I character face overcome
mainly I'll just I'll just use I'll
learn them that's the one so then yeah
then never made ones no there was no
doubt Lord hold man what would will be
your mic drop moments what would what
expectations what you want from this
direct well I think Nintendo's usually
for the past couple years kind of seated
the ground with what they're planning to
come out with so I'm not expecting a ton
of surprises but what I would really
love to see is on the hardware side I
would love to see his switch with some
more juice you know there were some
rumors about a switch Pro a switch plus
something like that I love the switch
but just a little bit more juice would
get me a little bit happier about things
like the Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 and
things of that nature other than that I
see them bringing more we use stuff and
more we stock I do and there's a lot of
stuff to bring I think that they could
have a Metroid Prime trilogy in addition
I think they could have those Zelda's
Skyward Sword Twilight Princess winwaker
brought up to the switch and and maybe
something off the wall like Tokyo Mirage
sessions something from like that series
because I think the Shin Megami Tensei
stuff is still out in the wind somewhere
from the announcement from the launch of
the switch so I think that could be
useful again for kind of consolidating
that Japanese market but I expect a
relatively surprise las' III but wait
maybe with some cool hardware news no
doubt Lord stealthily back sir let me
see if he's if he's back ok anyways it
so what about GRU what are your
predictions like what what could be some
hot moments you might drop moments that
would get you all excited about this
direct yeah I have quite a few
predictions view I've revealed on
Twitter some I haven't but I'll start
with smash bros and i do think we're not
gonna get just one character I think we
might get two characters from the pack
one will drop the day of Nintendo's
presentation the other will get teased
or dropped but I definitely think we'll
see - whether that's you know apparently
Monster Hunter character or you know
even potentially maybe a Microsoft
character Steve Rowan craft or banjo oh
they even floated the idea
yeah yeah I even floated the idea of
maybe you know maybe Sakurai coming out
on the Microsoft stage and announcing
it's something crazy that would be
anything yeah but um you know I I do
think it made much just because of the
fact no just because of the fact that
it's intended Microsoft kind of you know
leading this thing this year it might be
the e3 could be the time for the
Microsoft character yeah you know in
terms of Square Enix I think we might
maybe see a bravely default HD
collection coming to switch um you know
I think we might get some Kingdom Hearts
ports even cards ports Kingdom Hearts
cut real quick
Eric's I know you've got to go buddy
thank you so much for being in the realm
of the Lord's might be like catch on
post e3 so much okay guys continues
feldman yeah some great great dog
tablets going off so great up picks
let's go yeah so um for for Capcom I
think we could see the announcement of a
monster like in not world but one being
built for switch getting out I do think
they'll be more crazy third-party
announcements that we didn't see coming
to switch then yeah I I do think
Nintendo will have one or two 2020
announcements um not many you know they
always say oh we're gonna focus on this
year and then the first thing they down
to something from you know the next year
they did that last year the first thing
they noticed was the 2019 game so you
know I do think there's a possibility of
that but you know again they have astral
chain they have Pokemon the Kappa Delta
they have Mario maker
they have Luigi's Mansion they have
oh c'mon they have so much this year
that they don't really need to announce
and all these games we've only seen a
trailer or we haven't even seen anything
so it's not like we've been flooded with
information about all those games you
know so you know even if they just show
that it'll it'll be great but um
I do think most of like the really
shocking stuff will come from third
parties of games that you didn't think
we're coming to switch but are okay now
let me ask you this - Lord hogs point in
reference to hard wigs I know that's
been yeah interesting surgery in the
realm um you know we're hearing we heard
rumors of the mini we're heard rumors of
a pro then it kind of flipped flat with
no parole
you know what are you hearing in that
regard oh is it any chance we get
hardware at this direct none they they
were pretty explicit they said flat out
that there's not gonna be hardware at e3
um you know they have they lied before
yes you know they were pretty adamant
about it just really do they even now
it's hard word I get a announce pretty
SAT three but you know there's I don't
think there's any chance at all that
they'll announce hard word in fact it
might be is something as silly as they
announce it in the direct like two
months later but not specifically at e3
you know if they don't have a mini that
costs $1.99 before and my crossing the
Pokemon come out that would be insane to
me um so I like that so I do think
something will be announced soon just
not at e3 because they said so God you
predictions I like what I mean
Lord de Lappe oh man what what would
make you go crazy so mic drop moments
things that it gives you height but it's
direct alright oh you're gonna Final
Fantasy seven us and show us another
logo for Metro Frank for another you
said Final Fantasy 7 remake I don't
think it's I don't think it's not a
question I really don't I
I do why why why do you don't agree I
don't think the switch can run three
edges don't I just don't think the
switch can run the remake 15 the pocket
before I get back to level you had some
interesting comments in reference to the
square and Nintendo relationship and the
fact that us do you think that they
would want to get pretty much a lot of
their tiles away or do you think that is
the possibility that the Fantasy 7
remake could happen to the levels work
well just to kind of put it put that
into contact Square has put squares
announce lash released over 25 games for
switch in under 2 years so there they're
putting a lot of stuff on switch you
know even Dragon Quest 11 which is you
know arguably like one of their pillar
new titles next into Kingdom Hearts 3
and you know
I mean honestly quite frankly I think
any I think most games could be ported
to switch but most teams don't want to
put the time into making it work you
know if they gave it to virtuous or if
they gave it to panic button mmm could
they do it probably but you know if they
only have a skeleton crew it's square
with like five people are they gonna
want to invest that time probably not um
you know I've seen so many games that
people have said oh that'll never be on
switch is on switch um you know it just
it just depends on the budget they they
want to put into porting it and most
companies don't want to put anything
into porting and anything to switch
basically it makes more sense to put a
title like that on the switch as opposed
to the Xbox which we've seen them do
multiple times then they're like oh my
gosh why didn't this sell on the Xbox
we're so surprised it's just it's just
demographic it's different graphic
friends and that's where that's how I do
want you like what that nonce because
there's a server in the development for
Final Fantasy 7 remake this is a time to
play development impossible I do think
we have a really good chance of seeing
persona 5 this e3 on looking can you
play the bill sir okay Final Fantasy
remake will be announced for switch Pro
later this year or early next year
that's from JD game sir I do appreciate
it and you will get me you know JD not
matter we you know what's what you
brought to the table I do believe that
first party standpoint I think we're
gonna see some shake ups from like the
franchise's that we know I really would
like to see and I hope they do this with
Animal Crossing I would like to see a
fully multiplayer like an online
multiplayer version of she was did I not
say at the beginning of the podcast I
don't mess of animal cross but I know
it's got its it's it's bad bass so you
cool down with that too it would
actually I feel like the animal crossing
the really fan base really take to that
right it would give me a reason to stick
around person like past the first five
minutes cuz it's a game about dead and
that's it's so dumb to me but there's
such a there's such a hardcore fanbase
around here I'm having this very
successful franchise I don't know if my
but I really do hope they do something
to pull so that's what you got for your
you might drop your moments that you
need Lord Aleppo no mine mine was the
banjo thing he told I really do think I
think banjos I think though
Oh Lord at it I need your mic drop
polish things that it gets you hyped for
this direct man you know people say they
don't like remakes but when it comes to
Nintendo games I'm about that remake
like TV shout out to let me pierce my
black brother was going on switchport so
hopeful or hope you kind of say oh
really
reports are done by side dev and not the
main dev even Mortal Kombat 11 wasn't
done by you know what like I think what
I would be happy with is a Luigi's
Mansion 3 released a relatively close
probably like September ish Halloween
that make sense I want that I want a
little bit more info on Pokemon but I
want them to do a whole 30 minutes on
focus so you what go directly with Lex
it's no I don't know I said I don't want
them to do a whole like I would be okay
with flight than ending it with like
seven or eight minutes no good strong
two minutes no don't don't get a twist
they're gonna spend a good amount of
this of this direct on that game okay
okay that's that's the best of probably
one of the biggest games if not their
biggest thing coming out this year I
think so
and then my Mike the drop moments call I
said I wonder would be if they if they
did what they did with the game queue
and they dropped the collection of all
the zealots I would lose my mind if they
hey real quick real quick cuz I
asked you that I got stealth and you in
a green wait wait is this pigs fly
moment or is just like real moment
because what happen I mean because I can
say stuff dude
I thought you want a real stuff oh boy
well I don't think that's you know going
to happen but I do think it can it could
realistically happen to probably want to
go i I just don't think they'd be like
HD remakes I think they would just I
think they're just poor your 3d yes okay
via B I want to backtrack when your
zelda comment because you and actually
still have a lot attic you guys have a
bond when it comes to zelda in reference
to dungeons in its place in in zelda
games so like where do you boast in on
that you still in that pockets they'll
fanatic you are as the great age I think
birth of the wallet had to probably had
the trashiest dungeons that's ever been
in zone Wow stealth to you like I don't
even consider them dungeons they're like
they're like the many dungeons that you
go before you go to the dungeons and the
others Ellis Louis tell that your degree
would sir I'm not sure I would call them
trash but that's but but but because of
you know how not great they were like
I've mentioned I wouldn't put it in my
top 5 Zelda games but yet like dungeons
are very very important to me when it
comes to solder well I was going back
and playing some of the odors odors and
then it like it hit me yeah though that
breath of the wild had some really bad
really really bad
dungeons like was wonderful they were
casual friendly I thought they were
delightful if you can literally go from
one to the other right and then like you
know go across the map open up the the
mechazords you could literally probably
do them all in 30 minutes yeah and
that's the best part about it that's the
oldest regardless how many how many
years you played how many times you've
played it there's some Zelda's that
literally will take you two hours to do
even if you know what everything I want
the same exact team to work on the news
okay
same squad thank you that you some type
of a package of oldest elders that would
be like an ultimate it would like if
they gave winwaker you know it winwaker
or majora's mask could be enough okay
because i think you know there's some of
the best sodas out there I think
Twilight Princess I just if I got
Ocarina of Time Majora's Mask would
Waker and Twilight Princess and like
that that 3d bundle of links yep legend
is out it like that would be enough they
can I can charge me $100 for that we all
know Nintendo's numb games together my
[ __ ] probably not but if they did that
I would ya but they did it for the
launch of a console like I think we're
past that now but I do think it could
happen to I think it's going to happen
probably not bundle games they stay
still bundle games they just did like a
Kirby pack on like the we like and when
the Wii was done and they did a back for
the Wiis so still selling the Wii for
$400 I'm not saying nothing is out of
the realm of possibility in your eye on
Astana I think they could do whatever
they want but I think it'll be exciting
to watch you know probably besides that
I would just want some you know more
third-party stuff that is you know
portable friendly like XCOM like that
like I might joke around but even at the
division to a destiny to was on the
switch I'm still not playing it on the
sewage like I prefer games like XCOM
stuff like something I can easily you
know go to the airport quite late man
XCOM war to chosen to something like
that even if they went back to the first
ones I'd be happy yeah and that's all
that guy really do because for the most
part like my xbox I play third party
stuff so my PC
ah you know don't really do much on the
PlayStation like the games is coming out
this year that I actually in any
remotely anticipating or on the switch
so duh
fair enough Lord solve my switch
brethren my core these boys back in your
King uomini no games are we fraud
PlayStation 5 sure but you got to swipe
it that's when you need to show until
then sir continue it again why whatever
you want I want your camera on when you
bend in the knees I don't hear nothing
you just make sure their cameras on I
want the telephone with the 4k nerves
why is it that you guys love me man you
guys really love to jump in on my
segments as soon as Lord sovereign comes
as somebody we need your predictions so
just simple predictions upfront like
things that could happen like more Wii U
stuff I could see peak men getting a
converted and brought to the brought to
the switz um I can see Samus returns
finally coming to the switch from the
3ds I can see that happen JD gamer with
the $2 super Jack somebody tell me who's
been bending the knees question let me
give you one true answer Sony has been
been
No there you go JD thank you for
bringing into the realm I do appreciate
that you all continue yeah yeah may be
Prime trilogy we do get that at some
point I don't know it might be we don't
I don't think we're getting any Metroid
Prime for stuff Oh
and not even announcement or anything or
trailer or anything like that um so I
may be the prime trilogy
um maybe something is kind of out there
I think maybe we get apex legends on
this which oh yeah yeah I think so man
Oh like I think why not they've already
proven that they can it can run on a
phone you butter lotion me to some till
this day please I must be dizzy you
might be honest um you know and they
must you know hit that like button cuz
it's 70 90 now all that other stuff that
you wrote in is crap but I do say that
is fantastic this you have worked up a
great point thank you come again
I think Impex they've already proven it
can run phone so I don't see why it's
not gonna come to the switch that would
be a cool little I always I would say
boom because I think it's Alan with
states dying down on consoles and PC but
it's kind of plateaued a little bit it
could jumpstart a little bit by putting
it on there but for me the mic drop
moment would be anything that involves
Microsoft coming out on stage before I
think we're gonna hear more I think all
the experiments they've had in Japan
with the streaming and the cloud stuff I
think they're finally gonna bring that
over since Microsoft they're going big
on cloud it would make sense that
Nintendo have something there to talk
about as well if that partnership
continues so
for me you know for coming out on stage
somebody coming out on stage talking
about you know um whatever their their
cloud service on on you know Azure or X
cloud on the switch showing off I I
guess they had res equal seven they had
AC Odyssey so something involving that
would be great I think I said might drop
moment for me okay I need your mic drop
moments what would get you excited okay
now uh hyper blue stuff is I don't work
you know a Christian on the star stuff
is gone
I want intend o to actually release the
restraints that they put on the switch
there's three different modes that your
switch runs that I'm shout out to
digital foundry for putting this
information out there and and I want
them to release the switch because when
we went to pax we saw these switch games
running beautifully right no my this is
why I don't think there's hardware
that's in the future this is why I I
gotta say stuff is right on this part um
there won't be any hardware announcement
you've been purposely holding a system
back that you can release the secret
sauce and allow these games to actually
take advantage of it and and show what
the switch can really do we knew since
the switch was basically a trimmed-down
version of the Nvidia shield and the
Nvidia shield is a very powerful system
um and I just wanted to switch to live
up to that day that power spec oven so
if we can get them to release that and a
lot of the games to run in an optimized
fashion I would love that um that would
be my mic drop moment um and as far as
them saying something like okay since I
was doing hyperbole maybe in my camping
Oh
me personally I know game pastors coming
and I hopefully it comes this year
oh I'll be fire you man I would love
that kind of stuff I mean we all want to
say it's at the time for me nobody
mention my Astra chains I would love
more information
I'm super high for that despite the
lavos hate but I think that's they turn
to drop the ball you don't say well we
say we got to see man everything I've
seen so far looks okay but uh Metro prom
full that would be crazy I think that'd
be nice um let me see yeah I think I'm
wait I'm with us though I think
definitely another smash character gets
it now cuz I believe they have like that
a tournament going on at that time would
III part of their announcements and
stuff like that hopefully Animal
Crossing spicy takes now let's see um I
would hope LV Lin if that Final Fantasy
7 remake y'all said somehow get an ounce
I mean we know you know like I said
stealth is on it like we know that
relationship is there the question is
like addict said can it run it though is
you're gonna get a pocket move yeah you
got it remember you got a pocket final
fantasy fit you won't get pocket final
fantasy remix w-what would hope that you
know these guys are working feverishly
to try to get that thing on their you
know depending on the engine and stuff
like that and me personally and I think
hoga appreciate it
I want that discord at partnership
because clearly the online is now where
they and a shout out to discord they put
out a tweet recently people were asking
them like hey would you ever consider
you know bringing the app over to
Nintendo and they said yeah we have no
problem it's up to Nintendo to agree on
it so they want to be in business with
them and it's very interesting I know
it's a sensitive thing I know Nintendo
does not just automatically allow people
in on the backend and they probably some
security confession yes would you be
okay if they did bring discord but it's
behind the paywall yes I would pay I
would pay I'd have no problem paying I
mean listen I mean stuff like I mean we
as far as the the price of it I think
that's the only way that would ever
happen right it's a good smore I'm there
pay well it's so cheap I mean do you
think it's out of the realm of
possibility stuff with this disclosure
I mean that's not out of the realm of
possibility how likely is that I'm not
really sure but what do you think would
what is more of the the holding up is
just a fact a Nintendo wouldn't probably
allow that type of sensitive information
exchange or like would that that that
that probably has a lot to do with it
okay so you saying it'll be interesting
because definitely that that to me you
know we don't want to talk about the
Achilles heel has always been online
infrastructure you know I'm saying and
despite SDKs I believe no Vox they you
know they're coming out with stuff and
you know they've gotten fortnight and
all that stuff to play nice together
invoice yet but it's not Universal
across all the games so that's my thing
and I know um shout out the unreal
because unreal in their latest SDKs and
that's supposed to be coming to Mortal
Kombat 11 later on they're talking about
that integration they're talking about
the messaging that cross played across
progression all that good stuff so it's
like it's there we know physically this
that you know the switch can do it I've
talked about this many prediction shows
already you know there so please even if
not discord and if not that then damnit
Bowser you bring Phil Spencer out when
that's and you say hey due to our
partnership you know and it's a trifecta
of global as your love and everyone's
kumbaya you know all together cuz man
they that's the only thing they need
they have a great system fantastic game
but that infrastructure man and I'm just
not of the mindset that you know just
download that I know that we all know
that after it's in the bushes like no
one's using that app it's not across the
board it's just too much of a mess you
know kind of thing and um yeah that
that's where I'm at with it as far as on
what I would like to see actually jump
in and say they like going on all day we
wasn't really drowning alright so let's
get to double up on two times which is
the Alliance's and then um to kind of be
an Achilles heel already but I want to
see al asses and I won't talk about
disappointment so let's talk a lot whole
um as far as alliances right we know you
know I was
we heard about the big you know the
talks of stuff like that with mark self
and Sony and stuff like that and you
know with Microsoft in general and
Nintendo you know I'm saying like could
you see anything like that going on do
you think that they are maybe things may
already be in the work and then the
second part of my question is as far as
the direct what would upset you what
would you not want to see well I think
in terms of alliances I think you can
continue to expect Microsoft a Nintendo
to strengthen their relationship cuphead
I suspect was only the beginning
Microsoft from on high which we've
talked about before but it's clearly not
driven by its gaming revenue Gaming is a
infant testimony small portion of the
Microsoft Empire and so they want to get
people in bed with them on a shore and
on any number of other things and so
they're gonna continue down that road
and I think that's going to benefit
Nintendo in terms of competition I think
both Microsoft and Sony view Nintendo as
supplemental to their product because
Nintendo can't necessarily run name your
high triple endgame your God of War your
days gone your halo whatever it is it's
not competing in that space and so it's
always going to be a possibility to have
an Xbox and a switch to work
conveniently together so I think that's
going to continue to get stronger I
think Microsoft is going to continue to
explore services and software even more
than its hardware space and its living
room solution and so I think that's
going to continue and get even stronger
in terms of disappointments yes I guess
if Nintendo had an e3 where they had
absolutely no surprises at all where it
was just Fire Emblem and Pokemon and
Animal Crossing and Mario maker I know a
lot of people are excited about these
games I would probably wind up buying
all these games because I can't help
myself and I buy everything but it's not
anything that is exciting to me as a
Super Mario Odyssey and a Zelda breadth
of the wild and those kinds of things so
I think the real disappointment would be
nothing surprising and sometimes
indirects are like that sometimes you
got Reggie on the front not anymore but
you've got red you got the front saying
wait until the end and you get to the
end and you're like well that wasn't
anything and
sometimes they're their own kind of
theatricality gets the better of them
and I think that's really the only way
they could stub their foot here is if
they get you pumped and excited for
something and then that something turns
out to be new joy con colors that's the
kind of thing that I've seen Nintendo do
in the past and they always kind of run
at risk so I think part I'm gonna take
it chill I'm gonna expect nothing and
I'm gonna let them surprise me I do
think there's a a wide opening for them
with Sony essentially opting out and
Electronic Arts and some of the other
third-party publishers opting out that
Nintendo could really control this e3 if
they come out with a with a strong
message and so that's my expectation and
I think really the only disappointment
would be if they don't come out strong
and if they don't reveal anything I
don't already know about lured stealth
alliances and then disappointments
sketcher takes on these - yeah I agree
with kind of the sentiment going around
with Microsoft but I'd be surprised if
both Ori games are announced for switch
at e3 or red or rare replay
um no I wouldn't yeah I'm not sure like
whose conference would be announced at
but ROM Microsoft did say that cuphead
was just a start
so um stuff is happening um you know in
terms of other partnerships Nintendo
will probably continue with what they're
doing in partnering with Japanese
companies Capcom not Kat yeah Capcom
Square level 5 I'm the only Tecmo um
those are the partners that they're
really most comfortable with say enough
now let's get into the disappointments
Lords though what would upset you at
this direct well it wouldn't upset me so
much as disappointment but you know and
any delays from the games that they've
constantly said or 2019 um that would
disappoint me
you know Animal Crossing we just Mansion
they've said 2019 2019 if that got the
laid out that would disappoint / upset
me you know I
I think they'll have a few first party
announcements um I'd like it better
paced than it was last year 30 minutes
on smash a little too much um even I'm a
huge fan of it they could have done that
at the treehouse they really could have
um you know and and the the the directs
that happened in September and you know
the one that happened in February both
way better than the one at e3 where we
liked em max it was like two minutes
agreed for an announcement and they just
rapid-fire them um you know I don't
think any game is gonna get 30 minutes
ago
I mean Animal Crossing is gonna get a
lot of time but it's not gonna get 30
minutes mm-hmm I am so with you I am
hoping everything you say yeah that's
mash direct killed me Lord I mean as
much as greater than Guinea miss I'm
like you like you yeah I mean in the
moment I loved it because I was in the
moment and everything was so hype I
loved it but then the next day I looked
back and even like the weeks to follow
there were a lot of switch announcements
that weren't at e3 but just were trot
him like hmm you know that that would
have been cool it III that would have
been cool it III and then I started to
think you know they probably could have
fit 10 new third party game
announcements in there mom that happened
like two weeks after III said they
couldn't because it was 30 minutes of
Smash Brothers and you know honestly
that trailer alone would have been
enough but then when he started getting
into the deep dives of all the
characters that that that's the first we
we went off the rails at that point
what's going on good day everyone been a
while glad to catch at least part of it
one live already know the show will be
fire tap that like button yesterday you
know
I gotta say you all right with that tap
dance but it baby and the show is live
you have brought
very very I do appreciate you certainly
Schmidt flag rhenium in your want you're
onto something
oh he's gonna stay green fun don't know
but anyways last disappointment was that
the last very very last one far as the
length of the conference window with
just a single title focus yeah mostly
would be if any game got delayed there
that that would really annoy me all
right Lord de la Pole alliances
disappointments so as far as like games
and things like that
I don't see Nintendo giving Microsoft
anything I mean we haven't seen them do
it right but I could like if they're
gonna give them something it's gonna be
like something out of there like DTC
tears
yeah well Microsoft means didn't endow a
lot more than an enemies micro on a game
standpoint but we all know your intimate
piss-poor don't care boycott the system
they're still playing the system that is
free money titles there but listen a lot
of people need to be strong thing and
once they've shown a better world take a
break I wish I could talk smack on
splatoon I wish I could Nintendo
specifically locking me out because they
know I would roast these children are
you saying that you're the reason I
would like to see you guys get like you
know at least Bayonetta 2 something like
that you know or Bayonetta 2 & 3 or
something you know because I feel like
that's more in line with what you know
your your fan base is about though it
may be Japanese it's still you know an
action based game it doesn't look as
political cartoony as other Nintendo and
you know titles and things like that so
I feel like the Democrats would be more
in line there maybe even splatoon
because it's a shooter you know
something like that but um I just like
to see I would love to see where he
comes in attendance which I think it
would do really awesome
I played the first I really like on game
pass game pass so freakin go guys but
that gave me the experience of having
Ori because I never I wasn't next box
person you know and then that game it's
something else yeah it's something else
it's beautiful it's a beautiful title
and so I think I'll do really awesome in
this witch ecosystem um what about
disappointment sir what would upset you
okay it's Bo I say this every year and
they do it every year I just I need like
the switch has something for almost
everyone except for like shooter lovers
but multiplayer shooter levels like we
don't have anything there you know
you're not caught about nothing like
that you know and it's really it's
really disappointing because I would
love to be able to play those like on my
couches I'm like now you know sitting
there and talking odd in combat the
phone game would you recipes Dominick
Brazil also the switch's trap thank you
you might be onto something like the $2
fee which I might say this he is right
rest in peace to dummy because I think
he's still waking up from a concussion
which a displacer no I just I would
really really like to see it's just some
sort of announcements to satiate that
market because it is there there are
gamers who want to be able to play those
types of titles on their switch and I
just I just need some shooters I need to
really Lord addict man let's wrap this
thing up means we got the Lord's and get
out of here we need alliances of
disappointments so uh alliances you
still think this thing with Microsoft
for whatever might happen and then what
would disappoint you I think definitely
happen regardless for people people who
seem to think that you know money isn't
enough reason to exchange technology
like that like people really be out here
thinking that
like Microsoft needs some Nintendo IP
said to sell them services and don't
work like that
games no come on at it Microsoft Scott a
service they sell it to the flight what
what more you guys want like do you guys
want okay this is what we're gonna do
okay with weed okay you got that Maui
over there okay we want that services
and you could use the mario thank you
sir they're gonna be like okay we need
those services and well alright how much
that's literally how that conversations
gonna go we and disappointment yeah
they've been getting a lot better on it
but I I kind of want more focus on the
switching out to three years
yeah do you think this is the year that
we finally transition over as far as
they're gonna announce a new color for
the we're starting to get away a little
bit from because if you think about it
like the Pokemon games weren't announced
on the 3ds test I'll probably do though
knows the poke I don't think there's
gonna be any 3ds games they were pretty
clear in their blurb that it was only
switch games thank God thank you stuff
and even like and even the last two
directs didn't have any 3ds games
oh thank okay good actually I forgot can
I can I say one more one more
mic drop real quick I just remembered I
would love bravery default
I would lose my mind
those are like the the hardcore like
Final Fantasy Perry days when they were
at their height I would love that
yeah to be honest with you I don't I
could see Microsoft drop of the ball
before Nintendo this year like pretty
much you got Nintendo kinda like like
was it they got a road map that they
would literally everyone needs to be
fired if they mess up oh yeah it was
someone said kind of like cruise control
mode where even if you know there's Sony
last year loca I'm gonna move to a
church and
zombies you mean they're gonna have
everyone leave the one location to go to
relocate to another location using
musical instrument playing when he said
of bravery default will be clutch yeah
listen no it's not a path traveller
sequel I hope you can act upon that
traveler price reduction can we get that
can we ever get a say you can it's
called buy it on Steam a cartridge
titles big backer like I haven't played
it has another not mean Tendo is
straight like it's the Mafia with the
game price but the pay for it and the
thing is you're not getting the
reductions on on hard copies that you
you sooner see a digital reduction in
price and then I that's no because it's
a psychological thing like you you
associate like when you see two things
you associate like you thing with like a
higher price tag with is part of an
tendo's voucher program so you
technically can definitely get holding
stuff on that but lord king would you do
the honors sir we need to put some more
respect on his arse name Nintendo Online
is look there's the basement of King's
Landing and you bring such to the
podcast all right now with all this
ah to get home
I gotta get spelt on this we didn't even
talk about it attic you made a great
point as far as the voucher program we
didn't even talk about that like how do
we feel about this Nintendo finally
being a little bit more
consumer-friendly especially in the
digital space where you at home don't
you think I gotta be nuts with you guys
got to tell me what the heck the voucher
program I mean I can explain it it's so
basically you know the last one I
apologize again I don't love Mario maker
I didn't catch the other
so basically digitally Nintendo is
taking a list of games that are still
59.99 some of them a little cheaper but
still you'll get a discount so basically
you can buy two $59.99 games or $49.99
games together for $100 you know what
that means though so basically you save
$20 normally and this is a way for them
to lower the price a little bit but then
have you buy two games that means you
can finally get that one to switch that
you've been saving for actually that
that's part of the list I'm happy to do
it with any of you when you like that's
that's the same solution we're not calm
that's the same solution that a number
of folks came up with in the early days
the App Store at Apple because they had
$0.99 priced minimum and some people
wanted to sell it for 50 cents or what
have you because that's the development
cost that they wanted to put in so they
got together these separate developers
got together and wound up selling
packages of things for $0.99 and whatnot
so I mean I think it psychologically
gives you what Nintendo wants to do
which is they want to have in your head
these things are $60 or $40 whatever
their full retail price is and they
never go down you're never going to get
a discount on those they want to retain
that value and in fact if you're
following the PC space that's exactly
the kind of thing that you're seeing in
the epic game store right now I know
we're not talking about that today but
when a number of companies took their
product always are about that because we
fail
that's that's in my opinion that was a
communication failure between epic and
some of their developers because some of
the developers aren't comfortable
reducing the psychological brain space
for what the value of their game is
right now and certainly in a pre-order
location so this makes a lot of sense to
me for what Intendant wants to do which
is yeah they want to hold the $60 price
for that game but they want you to be
able to get it for $50 as long as you're
also giving them more money so but the
really smart thing about it is all new
summer games are going to be compatible
with this so Mario maker Fire Emblem
Marvel so you can buy these new games
you can buy two of them together for
cheaper digits but do you think they'll
deal with Pokemon I think a lot of
people you know they'll buy both Pokemon
here you could just find low for them
for it's disgusting how many Pokemon
people buy both versions I don't know in
the trade system so busted now it
doesn't even matter you can get exactly
what you want money vouchers they said
that these things were for a limited
time - yeah and if this anybody that I
expect to stick to something like that
isn't intended through the summer but
still even having those summer games
compatible means a lot of people are
gonna buy switches over the summer this
is an impressive list I'm looking at it
now you got your Xena break with that
you put that in the Google hangout yeah
definitely put that up yeah I mean it's
literally every Nintendo first-party
game that they've published from 2017 to
now so again it's a two-for-one kind of
a situation you must buy for a Ben
Sherman let's be real okay they do
they're really stubborn when it comes to
a lot of things but you know they do
have a lot of consumer friendly stuff
like they got the the rewards program
like I've literally bought a whole $60
title just from buying games like yeah
you're sure everyone else has that they
got the voucher program now like like
Nintendo is far behind on a lot of stuff
but they do low-key you get you get 500
gold coins if you buy them out
Mario maker deal is maybe even better is
for $70 you get Mario maker and 12
months of online so you say for what I'm
gonna buy yes so basically it's ten
dollars for a year of online which you
know Nintendo's online isn't nearly as
good as Sony or Microsoft but ten
dollars for a year that's crazy and you
get the NES yeah and you get Karis Mario
maker to on it
Zelda what's yummy people that need to
pick up a switch and pick up Zelda in
Odyssey it's impressive
her real story matches on there -
smashes on there poke the let's go okay
yeah you don't get to do another price
game pass I mean yeah it's still the
best possible thing you can do hey I set
up my dad with an xbox in the game pass
and he was happy as a pig in slop
for months and months and months tell
him about that hope tell him about what
game pass do for people
well at the time that I got it for my
father I think game pass was offering
three months for a dollar or something
long run so yeah he wound up playing all
sorts of things and I think it's about a
hundred and fifty games it's to me this
is the same kind of thing they're trying
to move into invasion and though is 200
I'm in favor of the game pass mind you I
got to play crackdown 3 and then I
didn't have to play it anymore
I would like to ask you who did that for
you well Xbox made crackdown 3 and game
but to me for a dollar so that's right
Hogue and you had such a great time well
I might have overpaid a bit traveling
King you got fitness boxing on this list
now I don't listen
let me explain something to you that
list is not enthused me I'm not even
looking at you listen
Nintendo being in general does not
surprise me sir unless that list imagine
four people that pick up the switch and
they can get that one to switch yourself
in life if you're going if you're gonna
buy a new switch out you're available
you can get two games for cheaper like
yeah viz awesome if they can get their
version of game pass and all those first
party games is free that will be super
awesome but that by 2 foot is different
for the discount so yah so brainwash
drinking the whole kool-aid in London
but the kool-aid it's cool rights good
over here yeah listen and I feel you
when you said I'm buying these two games
anyway I'm saving 20 bucks good thing
but I think I think King is right in so
far as intend oh who set us on the $60
path otherwise if we're looking at an
Xbox or Playstation game and it's from
2017 and they reduce it out of the
goodness of their heart to $50 I don't
think we'd be having the same kind of
conversation yeah I mean so also you'll
you also have to understand that
Nintendo's selling more software on
switches and pretty much you know any
system they ever have so they really
have you know they're only doing what
the market is telling them to do yeah I
do have a quick question that I want you
guys answer real quick
mmm-hmm top three Indies is something so
our that's on the switch I would
definitely include a story in that love
stories later dead cells into the breach
no I say pass thank you I don't mute bye
bye
yeah they have a so many old a message
that's mine
yeah that's my big shout out to my boy
over there the best oh yes I know dead
cells shovel knight and I think really
Matta that I was telling you about
earlier this is a lesson that Sony needs
to learn
don't ever bite the hand that feeds you
all right we're just doing something
awesome for loop but PlayStation they
effectively ignored the start the Indies
gave them okay you come up from the
start right now
all that stuff early I mean I think was
more I don't know it is one of those
didn't have any game sir and when they
got big games they threw y'all right
back into the bushes I mean it's not as
bad as them you know as far as their
translating for their sales I mean
they're doing quite well what they have
I mean I got another one to hit you with
mm-hmm what's that what is what is the
best game on the switch come on a while
yeah I gotta say breath with a while
they say in breasted oh no it wasn't the
best Zelda game but it's still a great
game like I would say Oh Donkey Kong
tropical freeze now what you want to say
with Nintendo but you might be on
Jonathan be man if you say that again
I'm at the time yeah like you can't put
Mario Plus rabbits keen to battle in the
first game on this way yeah I would say
breathitt a lot just cuz I'd rather
count spiders what are you funny I would
say only for the simple fact that I'll
never forget that trailer and how
influential it was
selling switches to make people believe
in switch like I'd never forget him
climbing up the wall and the music and
it just how it looked and just when we
got it just that full you know open
world experience and people were like I
think it really converted a lot of
people into home console like
experiences on the go and the impact was
tremendous I think that once they rode
that wave it was no looking back so yeah
I have to say better well in that pretty
stuff what do you have is your top
switch game well I I talk about it quite
frequently but um
Xenoblade 2 is probably my favorite
sweater how many hours sir oh yeah oh my
god
500 at least they've been patched no I
gotta go back to try to get I played it
with her first came out I actually was
really enjoying it but some light it was
rhymers it was running really bad all my
life yeah I mean it's better in TV mode
but in my opinion it's it's better than
Final Fantasy 15 it's better than
persona 5 it's it's the best normally
it's the best jrpg this generation
before that's kind of marshmallows that
you it stick to itself a marshmallow
being cooked um of it's better than 15
seconds to my convictions that's what I
want to hear man real quick you got to
get out of here and I got to get out and
get solves prediction is my drops man oh
you got that I was the microphone
I think the alliance is again it goes
back to the the Microsoft thing
Microsoft was going big on cloud it
would make sense for Nintendo to make
some mention to that like I said like
they they tested all the stuff in Japan
say do you really think like the
Nintendo the the Sony announcement of
Microsoft was was by accident as well
like you got to remember these all these
companies are realizing that a unified
message on something that you know they
all want to do is the only way to really
sell this stuff and move it forward like
if they start if they start acting like
all I don't care about cloud I don't
care about this the it's gonna segment
the entire industry and because if we
look back if Microsoft had going all-in
on VR the same way that
did it Sony did and if Nintendo had done
the same thing at the same time as Sony
did we all would be in a different place
than it is now right
and so I think they realized that and
this the messaging behind cloud is gonna
be a unified front message so I think it
would make sense that they say something
about cloud and Microsoft being on the
stage is what I think you know would
push that that forward we for now yeah
now something that I don't want to see I
don't want to hear anything about
Nintendo online like I don't want to
hear song unless you're telling me
unless you're telling me like you're
adding SNES games or GameCube games if
you're adding the entire library or
something like that at least give me at
least give me a framework for when
that's gonna happen I don't want to hear
about changes that you've made to the UI
I don't want to hear about I don't want
to know and and in terms of the the
hardware I'm beyond it's like we still
do with two weeks away this is around
the time to to open three weeks away
it's around the time that people start
actually leaking stuff like that's
actually real or just talking about
stuff they don't plan to talk about at
e3 so I don't I don't think it's out of
the room possibility that they talk
about
if the mini is real and coming this year
they could talk about it b43 stuff says
no stuff says no hardware man they shot
us then obi 483 before e3 in that next
completely why as far as okay okay okay
you guys say it's semantics then it's
not they won't talk about they'll talk
announce it beforehand not during e3
they'll announce it beforehand it'll
still got a couple weeks out so you
never know I think you got a question
before king does his alliances and I
think and what you call it this point
I'll do it after he does his king
alliances disappointments of this direct
alliances um Marcus love like everybody
else knows wasn't gonna you know this is
just make it official put the ring on it
[Music]
sitting there talking to other people no
don't do that
you put the ring on Sony put the ring
all right um disappointments yes what
would would you date despise you saw
that direct uh
no okay well being that you put this
this new thing that they're doing with
the swapping game in this sales that
kind of scares me into thinking that
game path will not be available for that
in any formal fashion while they're
rolling out this get your wallet
production thing my disappointment would
be if they if they do the same thing
that they did last year but like the
smash brothers with any type of game any
game it's the last long thirty minutes
and doing listen I would love to see
more games I look forward to your direct
so you can give me that rapid-fire it
kind of lost the mood Oh like what a
direct was and it seemed like a homage
to smash brothers so I don't want that I
want people to stay engaged so I don't
want to lose interest in a game just
because you oversaturated it to me so
just um show multiple games show what
you got coming for this year just a
little bit more of Metroid so my
disappointment be if they actually just
stick on one game just drag it out NAAFI
yeah for you on that attic well you got
some say before I go when we wrap up
yeah before you wrap up I had one thing
one more question what what game do you
are you guys the most hyped for Zelda
there's a whole yeah I know for me is a
strain you already know for me it's
Pokemon oh but the fact they have so
many games that we haven't really even
seen any of that we know we're coming
out this year it's pretty exciting the
better question to you is what starter
you using I'm gonna have to see what the
final evolution is for that guys see
what we got see what the looks like at
the ad gamer King oh we will see man
Tendo on Microsoft
I said already I really honestly believe
and this is going into Sony show um a
Microsoft prediction show I really
honestly believe only meant the need to
show up on Microsoft stage just on my
grop moment in my opinion I believe that
Nintendo can show up on microscope stage
what wait can Microsoft really shut III
down they already preemptively shut it
down early well um yeah I do I agree
which would you say agree the game
you're seriously on all seriousness we
do shave everybody uh contributing the
super check but I do and I will hope
that what happens because I would I
would like us to get back to everybody
you know like if you have a Nintendo
I'll go over your house if I don't have
it you know and all this bickering in
between systems is not really necessary
Oh doubt hope did you say your most
anticipated game no I didn't uh it's
probably Pokemon although I didn't
particularly love the direct so far I'm
looking forward to seeing what else
they've got in terms of that game no
doubt solve for me you'd be surprised I
think it's the Ultimate Alliance for me
be honest I wasn't a big fan of the
other ones put that you know that new
hero camera angle like the person behind
the back thing like I prefer to play
games like that so that to me has me
really excited about that game and I
wouldn't even be mad if they'd milk me
for DLC for extra characters the big box
of that but the game it formerly doing a
tremendous
expose on it right now so Miles Morales
in there man it looks like they've got a
lot of character so I'm definitely a
that's always I saw I forgot about
ultimate lab man that looks great yeah
man and as far for me I'll wrap up on
alliances everyone you know the
roundtable is inconveniently all think
the Microsoft thing possibly is it is
inevitable most likely and I'm saying
we'll see you know the talks were early
you know and we'll see if they continue
and maybe manifest itself on the stage
on for me again I'm gonna agreement with
a lot of loads here the one game focus
as far as disappointment I do not want
to see a one game focus they need to
keep their consistency with what direct
is
and bam bam title title you know if
you're gonna spend you know have a lot
of time on one you know five to five
minutes maybe you know saying but I
don't want to now this man is not a lab
oh you're gonna build your own the last
thing and solve probably good not like
this but hey I would like you know them
to talk about some features to the or
Lasser so I would like them to show
improvement for my twenty dollars I
would like to see pay for that yeah
Pokemon bro bring the price down he's
down the to you show me where the price
is down a new d-pad that I have a third
party so you know is the problem we need
a mini this is a d-pad this is this is a
deep that's why we need a mini stuff
that's not a defense oh I would love a
meeting
I would love some hardware I doubt it
you know come with a deeper hey if
important background talks if it's
portable
we got now that he can't switch out
listen you got the big boy for that
functionality right you got all that
stuff that you need if you want to cut
costs take out the amiibo sensor thing
take out the joy concept I just make it
a more you know something you have been
brought out by Nintendo oh you gotta
make sure that you put the T in the
corner anyway that's all I got on the
prediction series first of all solo to
the round Lord our tools you had to
leave a little early loss stealth for
240 K Lord hold Lord potentially perfect
in the realm concluding the e3 2019
prediction series so let's start off
with Lord spell tremendous takes
outstanding knowledge where can the fine
people find you what you have going on
sir they can find me on twitter at
stealth 40k and thank you for reminding
me that I used to have the underscores I
didn't realize you were researching me
that much look I need o come for pain
absolute pleasure man you know you are
welcome back in the realm of Lords any
time against tremendous takes learned a
lot man and it's good to see what one
day we're gonna get this YouTube channel
right stones man and wait min someday um
my full-time job is kind of making that
impossible right now I hate I hate it
would great day I need to have you back
after the directors well justice see how
compared notes a little bit see what
happens that would be great but yeah
sounds good I Lord salut Lord
Hogman coming in in all 11 I also I
forgot to sell out salute mr. negative
you couldn't make it he and he was very
sick with his words but Lord Hawk
stepped up in the eleventh hour as a
true lord of the realm coming through
the hottest takes lava was in the
building we got new representation on
partnerships and agreements virtually
galley was in session where can the fine
people find you what do you have going
on sir that's right you know since I
started coming on here I have more stuff
to pitch now rather than just legal
services I know absolutely people can
follow me on Twitter at Hoag law and on
my youtube channel which is also
youtube.com slash hog law where I do
virtual legality I do talk about the
Microsoft Sony Alliance I did an hour
long page turn of the Apple versus
pepper Supreme Court decision about who
can sue who in the app store some fun
stuff there if you like that kind of
business in law encounter point and
right now I am figuring out exactly what
my episode six post-mortem for Game of
Thrones tomorrow morning what what what
kind of sigh I'm going to start the
post-mortem with and then something like
yeah well let's just say I think you
said if you get a 35-minute lab oh then
I'm not allowed back on the program I
think if I start doing a post-mortem
series on your favorite television show
you might just want to have me
assassinated I don't have talked about
Game of Thrones you're not allowed to
it's over we it's were past the Rubicon
its phones and pop-culture virtually
gala tea thank you so much for having me
you said absolute pleasure hilarious and
drops knowledge at the same time and of
course the Lord the young lord of video
production and shout out to Lord Goliath
with the tremendous
pre video hype if you want to know who's
got us hype for all these predictions
that is this man Lord de Lappe Oh back
in the realm doing his thing where can I
find you what you have going on sir oh
yeah they can find me pretty much
everywhere I I'm doing Twitter Instagram
moved in if you're looking for a p2
production Instagram so what are the
names we don't know it's under it's
under de la wish now because I'm
refocusing under my production work and
what I do with that kind of stuff and so
it still all be it's still gonna be
video game based but it's just a focus
on like the production that I put into
my videos what about the amazing hero
unlock series what can't
so that's right recently yeah that's
gonna be on YouTube potentially perfect
we I'm also refocusing on that making
sure that I like the characters that I'm
doing because yes we need that yeah but
yeah it's always a good time it's nice
to I think it's nice to learn videogame
history and knowledge like that from
someone who you know what they trying to
branch off into the home but they always
very good that you look back we give you
the tomb so you know where your Super
NES
things apart from sir there's a super
graph it's right there you see it I can
tell people hey look at this stuff from
back here dalabo absolutely just
focusing and the channel potentially
perfect still sir collect you too sir
yes man you already know and of course
the young wolf Lord addict what do we
have going on sir nothing I am making a
video on a Zelda at the moment I'm not
gonna really release too much
information on that right now I'm gonna
start doing a little bit different stuff
on my channel eleven uh looking into
some stuff right now so definitely look
out for that which is gaming at it it
was not Lord at okay gaming addicts a
different you know
a lot of f-bombs and stuff okay so
definitely look out for that appreciate
everyone that came by we had a pretty
good fall a pretty good pretty good show
turning but you know next week shoot do
you think we should announce it's not
yet do this thing
I like the lab work I like then we
hopefully I don't make him go crazy in
the last minute and change it and I
gotta teach you know how to put it on
for you or show you sir so next week at
a Sunday what day is that
26
we're having a Sony it won't be an e3
because obviously it's gonna be a Sony
for 2019 so I guess darkness Oh
need a Microsoft bring my Sony my Sony
squadron through we'll see you know be
looking out for that on Twitter will
announce the of the guests mm-hmm I
guess the reason one of the reasons
we're announcing the now is because it's
not really sentence though it's we wanna
make anyway Lord sovereign back in front
when this thing once again week and if
I'm gonna find you what you have going
on sir yeah shout out to everybody can't
do today Eric stealth hold the laughs
well thank you guys you guys awesome
yeah you can find me on Twitter Lord saw
IOP of course be excelling on PSN xbox
live hopefully get some gaming in this
week's like the fraud light cannot come
on see what happens but yeah just trying
to figure out the road to e3 man with
three weeks away we're trying to figure
out what kind of content we're gonna
deliver for you guys we just actually
just power out something really quick
this morning so you will get a
you'll get in the works yes I will start
turning my camera on when Solvers starts
turning his you will not see my face you
see my face plenty of III thank you very
much why do you want to see my face we
have plenty of paczkis videos up we
switch to disco where your face gotta be
up we go to the format the face eyes out
excited about that what we're gonna do
is gonna be interesting at e3 this year
so no doubt no doubt Lord King the king
of the statues and talk what do we have
going on so boy shout out to Bushwick
radio app that hosted us right yeah
hosting this week with my block brother
108 dragon-like little meet you are
loyal meet this the right hand of Zeus
go to his YouTube channel subscribe this
youtube channel and you can actually see
the live show then like if you want to
see the visual there and also you can go
to my Twitter page you can see that's up
and running there at all times
oh the back sir I believe you did can
get a statue who's that guy
that's the Punisher back there
please go to our YouTube channel and
check out what I posted on Kos Oh combat
talk with the Kings out we get me
talking about Deontay Wilder and his
upcoming fight with Dominic Brasil which
actually happened so if you can watch
the show over again if you came late you
can get the recap of what actually
happened yeah it was murder death kill
out here brothers definitely 100% on
deck he was serving up a slice of death
and I think Dominic Raziel took a big
bite of the pie oh oh
coming up we have ILP versus the world
we will avail that to you and you'll get
that oh go to e3 is when you unveil that
I have to know what that is I briefly
touched about it just waiting on some
stuff
also please I want y'all to go check out
LOCOG needles of first Comic Con um he
got a chance to see his childhood idol
and I want you how to understand how
very significant this is um this man
collect every book that Ron Lim was part
of that he drew if runnning Rollins name
was on it and had surfer to do with it
Kanye was there so when I found out that
Ron Lim will be at the Eastern Comic Con
that happened this weekend and it's
going on today so if you're in New
Jersey please go out there and go check
it out see Ron Lim jim Starlin and
George Perez which is our pillars in our
community
that's the iscap you know it that
pleased me that he got a chance to get
that off his bucket list
yeah when I thought I was so happy for
him I saw his ID you Latian that you
know he got a chance his first time out
there and he's out there on his lonesome
doing it um but you know god bless it
was fantastic I loved it I'm gonna watch
it again but yo salute you sir
oh yeah long overdue and for what
cocaine was saying yeah I mean check it
out it's up on our log podcast I call it
a little
cast in bait or actually searches for
the Infinity Gauntlet and our Lord home
would probably appreciate a little bit
actually jim Starlin the creator of
Thanos was there on leave Ron Lim like I
said one of my favorite pencil errs of
all time some huge Silver Surfer fan for
those who appreciate that kind of stuff
the origin of where these movies kind of
came from the comic book story the
Infinity Gauntlet saga Jorge Perez was
day as well shout out to him and with
val kilmer was in a building that was
interesting i'll kill me you know even
up now I mean Ronald Lim is my heart as
king knows like no one in my opinion Joe
Silver Surfer better and it was an
absolute pleasure to meet these guys
childhood heroes and yeah check that out
when you guys get a chance okay thank to
the beautiful panel like I said Eric's
stealth hold law as always potentially
perfect those are our guys coming
through you guys are welcome at any time
you know that and yeah ban order will be
up later on today we like our ad except
we have on the sony prediction series
coming up we will announce - guess it
will be a fun pattern guaranteed you
already know and of course check out the
great articles that we have up on modes
of gaming that net tremendous our little
baby jerseys add some stuff up myself I
have some stuff up please support the
Lords in the realm that is also
Stewart's out to the stream team I'm
forgetting you guys man Oh old school
style l-boogie PD MJ the boss man de la
Pole we miss you the laughs are we rich
man's working the man's work I'm just
teeth but I'm not salute everybody
robber turnout was fantastic we'll see
you guys next Sunday
please